alright we are alive hello everyone and
welcome to another google hangout I am
super excited today to have with me a
real Road Al and I'm so excited I'm so
excited have wrong with me so who is
Mayor Rodell she is the CEO of a real de
Inc they are the world's largest
independent publisher of of health and
wellness an environmental content the
the people behind men's health and
women's health the the the largest
independent book publisher in the u.s.
behind some of my favorite books I've
got two with me here the honest life
Jessica Alba and you can see all the
kind of sticky notes my wife is going
through this right now she's obsessed
and in on words by Howard Schultz in a
few you flip to the back you'll see you
know the Rodale logo there and you know
Maria has also been a lifelong advocate
of organic farming and gardening and her
grandfather basically coined the term
organic as it relates to food production
she is the author five books she has her
own blog she has her own shopping site
road ales and she is an avid writer and
Twitterer if that's a word and this is
her very first google+ hangout so she's
popping her Google+ chair with us today
Maria welcome to the show thank you so
much Evan it's so nice to be here
awesome so I've been doing this series
where I've been reaching out to
entrepreneurs and executives in an Aston
of what is one word that that they stand
for one word that kind of defines who
they are and I believe that when you
understand who you are yourself and you
can bring that to your life into your
busy
yes you're much you're breaking up here
a little bit be honest is her do we lose
Maria yeah I'm you I the screen stopped
on you for a long time so I couldn't
hear you for like the last minute I'm
sorry okay are we good now yes perfect
okay not not sure what happened there
with the internet but um basically
finding one word that that that you
stand for and find it to your business
and Jessica Alba has honest and Howard
Schultz has love and I reached out to
you on Twitter and said hey Maria what
is what's one word that you staying for
and you wrote back pretty quickly that
it was love and and so I was curious you
know what does what does love mean to
you and how do you apply that to your
business well he was funny because um I
had always had love as like my secret
word you know like pee-wee Herman's you
know secret word of the day but because
you know growing up in this business
growing up in a family business growing
up on an organic farm you know it's like
it's just there's a lot of love involved
and you know you kind of have to choose
to do it and love is the thing that gets
you through the good times the bad times
and the challenges but as you know woman
I felt oh if I say love is my word and
you know people might misinterpret it or
they'll think oh you're just such a girl
and it was actually Howard Schultz who
you know when we publish that book I got
to know a little bit and he spoke at a
magazine conference and somebody asked
him the question you know what it really
drives you and he said love it in that
moment I was like okay Howard has said
it I can say it and uh you know it's so
at that point I just came out of the
closet with a with love and and you know
I talked about it with my employees I
talked about with our part
hers I talked about with our customers
because you know it's really the driving
force in all of our lives and it's the
thing we all need and it even you know
drives positive change in the world
wherever it is so so ultimately I mean
you can nitpick about different words
and what they mean and business words
but that's the driving word for me for
sure do you remember what the first
thing you did was around love after
listening to that speech from Howard no
I just remember walking around going
like you know feeling relief like you
know it's okay to talk about this stuff
you know because it is a very you know
the business world can be very not love
oriented and um it was just a relief not
to have to keep it my secret yeah do you
still get people when you tell that you
know we're talking about love who rolled
their eyes and who say come on Maria
what are you talking about you know it's
really changed over the last um you know
because that conversation with Howard
probably happened maybe five years ago
yeah four or five years ago and I've
really seen a change over the last the
last few years and I think it's because
you know with the recession we've all
had to kind of take a step back and go
what's really important here you know
what's really important in our lives and
not just the recession but all the stuff
that's happening in the world and and
the whole world is sort of changing in
this direction when it comes to business
in terms of you know people want to buy
from companies that have a sense of
values and you know who really care
about each other in the earth and and so
and the people who roll their eyes it's
like you know be careful you know your
eyes might get stuck that way so Oh like
I want not one that's good
that's great so it's not that that's an
interesting coming coming out of the
closet story do you remember how you
first came up with it as your secret
word before you were willing to kind of
go public with it there is a story or
anything you can remember um I can't
remember like this specific moment um
well you know actually no I can't I can
sort of remember it um uh you know we've
had a lot of trauma in our families like
me and my father was killed when he was
60 in a car accident in russia you know
and nobody expected that and um you know
my mother had a lot of health issues and
you know there's you know in any family
business there's a lot of sibling you
know work that has to be done and I know
I remember sitting down with one family
business person and and she's like oh
god Maria I don't know how you do it how
do you do it and I said you know it's
really it's a spiritual mission for me
and you know so when I think about a
spiritual mission you know which I do
think about a lot it always comes back
to love that you know so it really came
from my own personal spiritual journey
of what's important and what's the thing
that unites people so I'm not a
religious person I do not belong to any
religion and you know I probably
probably won't find me belonging to any
religion but to me like love is the
thread that you know connects everything
in a beautiful way cool I love it and
this is interesting because a lot of the
people who are talked to I mean the show
is geared towards entrepreneurs people
want to start their own business or
already are in their own companies and
so mostly that I've talked to are the
founders of their company and and I know
you've started a lot with road ales and
with your blog and your own books but
the original business was started by a
grandfather and passed your father and
passed to you has love been a constant
theme throughout or is that kind of your
mark on the business that your
grandfather in your dad didn't bring uh
it's it's totally my mark because
well I think you know my father a
grandfather had love you know and loved
what they did they were very much from
that those their generations where you
don't show it you don't talk about it
you don't you know it was more about
duty and responsibility than about love
and for me you know as a
third-generation family member I had I
had to choose to do this and so when you
look at choosing something you know you
think you know what do I love you know
what's what's important to me you know
because if I didn't love it I wouldn't
choose to do it so how do you how do you
move that ship because you've got you
got a set culture you've got people were
hired who may be you know part of the
duty there on the duty train and now
we're shifting to you all about love was
that was that hard what did you have to
go through to do that um well it's
excruciating and it's an ongoing process
I think you know some ways the recession
helped because we had to make changes
anyway so you know you choose based on
you know it's this combination of like
shift I know I talked about as shifting
you know it's shifting resources
shifting attention shifting energy away
from those other things though you know
old things but and towards the new
things but I mean I've been working in
this company for over 30 years and part
of the benefit of being in a family
business is that you see that change
really does take time change takes
decades and so five years you know it's
a drop in the bucket ten years you know
it's a two drops in the bucket so so for
me for people watching it there's
somebody who who's in a family business
and they're about to take over and they
feel like you know they're very
different than their parents and and
some of their values are the same but
they just want to take in a different
direction but there's all of these
things that are slowing them down you
know you've been through that so what
kind of advice would you be able to give
somebody who's facing that same
situation um I mean the first and
hardest thing is um learning this
combination of like openness and
listening and learning and humility
combined with really trusting your own
gut and believing in yourself and
knowing that even when outside people
say you know and I've had I've had
inside people say you know well you know
you know why should I listen to you what
do you know you know um you know was the
last thing they said also I mean
somebody deal with the so it so you
kicked them out like how do you deal
with somebody who gives you attitude and
a business like that um you know in that
specific case it was someone fairly a
long time ago who all I had to do is sit
there and look at them and they
themselves realized that what they had
just said was completely inappropriate
and they resigned on a spot so um you
know sometimes you don't need to say
anything you just need to stay in your
place of truth and honesty but you know
I think the hardest thing for me has
been not only learning to trust my gut
but learning to have the confidence to
say this is what is is right and you
know or this is you know this year the
color is flamingo when it comes to eat
ailing and shopping so even from a style
Sam point you know having confidence in
that huh and so how do you how do you
hire people based on love what does that
process look like at your company well
I'm anything in in that case it's really
just kind of an expansion on the idea of
hiring forfeit I mean any good company
when you're interviewing you're looking
at a person and your list
and thinking you know will this person
fit in here because if they don't fit
they're not going to be happy and we're
not going to be happy so that you know
of course you know you want everybody to
have the right skills but if it's a
choice between you know super skilled vs
super fit um you know I'm going to go
with super fit and i'm not talking about
apps at this point and you know what
that where that fit cup comes from is
from you know love and passion for what
they do and what they're excited about
doing so you know to me I look at people
as I'm just a part of their journey and
Rodale is just a part of their journey
you know everybody's on this journey of
like self fulfillment and self-awareness
and self-development and you know so you
want to find somebody who's like kind of
going in the same direction and that you
want to travel with for a while and then
we know if there's direction changes you
know you wish them well in part ways so
for a lot of people watching you know
hiring and getting people on fit is one
of the biggest challenges that they face
as they grow is there a favorite
question you have or certain tests that
you like putting people through to try
to figure out you know are they right
for our business mm-hmm my two most my
signature questions are you know um what
do you love doing the most you know what
do you love doing the most but the real
telling question is always what do you
hate doing the most like what is the
thing that like is the last thing you'll
get to you know and and if somebody says
oh I don't hate anything then they're
completely lying and to me it's not that
like like if somebody says you know I
hate doing budgets that's okay and I
want to know that before you come in
because if this job is about doing
budgets then it's not right but if this
job is a creative job I know I need to
partner you with someone who is good at
doing budgets right that makes kind of
everything work better together
so so what do you hate doing most video
interviews oh come on I'm joking but I
doubt right I don't like TV I much
prefer Radio to TV um no I uh see what
do I hate doing the most um I'm not as
good at like you know following up since
you know it's funny cuz like there's
something about Twitter that it's so
immediate and easy that like it's so
easy to follow up with somebody but you
know if somebody sends me a long email
that's complicated and I have to really
focus and figure it out before I can
respond intelligently that keeps falling
to the bottom so that's that's on my new
year's resolution list is to get better
at responding to those i'll make a
mental note never send Marie a really
long emails to type reply I'm get weak
much easier so you have you have tons of
product right tons of product in all the
books you you create an end for your
road ales online store or and you know
how do you how do you go about picking
products based on love how does that
factor into the equation um well I mean
for magazines it's not about picking the
magazine I mean we would only do a
magazine if we love the concept and love
the idea because a magazine is such a
long term commitment you're in it takes
a long term to get up you know a long
time to get up to speed so every
magazine that we own we love I love and
everybody loves that's working on them
you know with books it's more you know
each new book coming in it's like you
know you're really you know it is very
it's a very intuitive emotional decision
as well as the strategic business
decision you know the strategic side is
does this person have a platform do they
how many Twitter followers do they have
you know are they going to help sell the
book
is this is the moment in time ready for
this but at the end of the day how you
decide yes or no is do we really believe
in this funk and belief is you know a
lot about love you know do we love it we
really feel passionate about it and I
can you know give you tons of examples
of like books we didn't love but we
published because it seemed like the
right thing to do and it doesn't usually
do as well as the ones that were really
excited about hmm so and then you know
in digital that's you know that's harder
because it's such it's so fluid and
moving in every moment so it's less
about what we love then what what the
users love and they show us love by you
know clicking or you know engaging
thinking about that that comment have
you had to say no to opportunities that
that really look great on paper but it
didn't feel right like it didn't mesh
well with with lava didn't it is in your
bone didn't feel right and you turn and
there is there a story you could share
um well you know I think definitely
people have come to us with
opportunities that uh look great on
paper and we've said no I mean um you
know I'm thinking you know the way you
worded it just now like you know time
when you know somebody was going to
offer us like tons of money for like a
fifty percent stake in the company and
you know you know I always say we're not
for sale you know but when somebody
offers you that big you know you really
have to say am I for sale or not you
know where's this company for sailing
and yeah it was easy inside for me to
say no but to get the words out of my
mouth when you have like a table full of
people who want you to say yes okay this
was a long time ago let's check you know
but um so I'm so glad I said now I'm a
thousand times but I said no and then
there's other like categories you know
that we are constantly you know looking
at
people are saying oh you know you should
get in the insurance business you know
health insurance you know and that seems
to make sense with what we do um but you
know I have no desire or interest to get
in the health insurance business so you
know it's not it's not who we are and
what we love to do so I'm glad it exists
but it's not for us got it so how do you
how do you find the confidence to to say
no I am you know thinking about that
deal as an example which somebody want
to buy you out and maybe your your newer
in your role and the whole room wants
you to sell and here you are saying know
how do how do you get that confidence
and to know that that's the right
decision to make um you know it's um it
really I mean it's a cliche but it
really is about listening to your gut
and like you know if you're sitting in
that room and people are looking at you
like that and every um you know little
micro organism in your stomach is saying
don't do it don't do it don't do it
don't do it you know it would just be so
in authentic and wrong of me to say yes
so you know and you know for me looking
back I can like really trace the biggest
mistakes in my life to when I didn't say
no or yes when Mike you know I when I
didn't listen to my gut those are the
biggest mistakes so you know you do it a
couple times and you learn yeah is it is
there one particularly memorable that
you review hearing is the one that's
particularly memorable um well you know
I launched organic Style magazine back
in like 2001 and it actually got off to
a really great start and was actually
exactly on plan and I had a buy that at
that point I had a really strong
background in
circulation but not as strong a
background in advertising and the CEO at
the time was like oh if this is going to
succeed you know it's gotta you know
we've got to grow the circulation really
fast we've gotta you know move the Edit
staff to New York City and you know I
was a lot younger than and I was like
you know people had said what do you
know and I was like well what do I know
I don't know what I know you know and I
said okay let's do it and it was the
death of that magazine it was death of
that magazine and it turns out i
actually did no more than I thought I do
sometimes I come back when you're making
a big decision now you think back to
that magazine and say I'm sticking to my
guns this time oh yeah oh yeah but it's
not it's not based on like emotional
with wishful thinking it's based on you
know experience and data you know I was
talking to one journalist in New York
business journalist who um you know I
think a lot of people look at me as a
woman and talks about love is like well
you know she must just shoot from the
hip or you know but no I mean I'm
intensely data-driven and so I you know
I'm a former circulation person which is
like very you know spreadsheets and you
know all sorts of you know analytics and
you know I don't want a part of trusting
your gut it's trusting that you know how
to look at the external data and
synthesize it and analyze it so the me
nothing interesting a lot of people
would see that as a in sharp contrast
love versus data howdy and you're saying
they're they're part of the same thing
how do you combine them how do you make
that work at your business well one of
the big aha moments I had um this goes
way back but I was terrible at math my
whole you know high school college
career I was not only I probably wasn't
as terrible terrible at it as I was
terrified of it and but at a certain
point when i started working at the
company I you know I asked the president
at the time
you know what is the hardest place to
work at in this company and if I work
and succeed people will like start to
trust me and he said circulation so I
was like okay here I go you know so i
went into circulation which is very mad
at math but what's great about cirque is
and the creative part of circus you know
you're seeing okay does this work versus
that you know which what resonates with
people and then I started to see numbers
as relationships it's really about
relationships and a relationship with
your customer in a relationship with
your customers so for me as long as I
can put it in the context of what am i
learning about people by looking at this
data and I love learning about people
and I love people then it's fascinating
that's where they come together
interesting that and so I mean you've
you've got a lot on your plate you've
got this huge company to run tons of
employees and now you've also brought
there and you've got your blog and you
launch Road ales which is selling
clothing other products how how do you
how does that all make sense how does
that expansion make sense in your world
where people might look and say hey
you've got this huge business to run why
are you off doing all these other things
as well um well I look at our mission as
really you know help you know our
mission is you know we inspire and
enable people to improve their lives and
the world around them and traditionally
that started with magazines and books
but as the digital revolution occurred
and we quickly data showed me that
advertising is never going to pay for
this and then I did a strategic analysis
of the marketplace and you know talk to
a lot of people and said okay where are
people spending money online you know
they're spending money shopping and in
truth you know we're telling people
giving people advice all the time in our
products you know try this or try that
or you know you should wear this or wear
that so to me it wasn't such a big jump
to
say okay we need to diversify our
business because print is at risk and
you know just doing free websites where
people isn't going to feed our employees
families so commerce is a real you know
option and you know there's a lot of
strategic in terms of figuring out how
it doesn't compete with advertising and
you know how it is unique to Rodale and
not you know just something amazon could
crush in it you know a sneeze or
something so i think what we ended up
with is something really great and fun
yeah I and I mean looking at your
business you've accomplished so much you
know hundreds of millions in revenue
what do you think of everything you've
done so far you're you're most proud up
and say you're like I'm really proud
that I did this in my business um well
it's a lot of things I mean I think you
know some of the books that we've
published that have really changed
people's lives are something I'm really
proud of you know we published BK BK SI
angers Iyengar's last book and and you
know it's still a huge seller for us but
it's an important book it's important
it's a book that like means something to
so many people and I mean I could you
know the South Beach Diet brought whole
grains to America you know before the
South Beach Diet there was no you know
whole wheat bread in your supermarket
and I think you know actually launching
Road l's was is something I'm really
proud of because it was not easy it was
not easy from a technical standpoint but
it was also not easy from a cultural
standpoint and then also writing my book
or organic manifest I'm really proud of
that because it continues even though it
came out in 2009 it continues to really
you know resonate with people and get
great reviews on Amazon so but you know
I think the biggest thing is to
the culture that we've created here and
the fact that I've evolved that culture
in a way that people love it's awesome
when you are looking at a new book
proposal is it something that you you
want people to have a deeper meaning and
people a deeper purpose behind it is
that part of the the process yeah you
have to you have to be standing for
something it's not just here's how to do
XYZ but you want somebody who's deeply
passionate what they're doing um yeah I
mean that's an interesting one because
you know I'm actually not the person
making the decisions about books every
day so you have to kind of trust people
and you know create a culture that
learns how to interpret that and it's an
ongoing process it's not something that
happens overnight and it's and you know
I pick and choose where to dive in for
closer management if there's you know if
I don't see that happening but in
general you know it i'm not a
micromanager I can't be a micromanager
that's one of the ways I you know
survive doing what I'm doing is I don't
micromanage unless there's this serious
problem and then and then you're not
going to get rid of me until it's fixed
song isn't not sending really long
detailed emails I love it listen um
we're bumping up against that the half
hour again most of the people watching
there they're entrepreneurs or they're
either just starting up or they may have
a couple employees or trying to get to
the next step and and they would you
know look up to someone like you and say
hey I want to be able to do something
like like Maria's doing what kind of
parting advice would you give to to
these kinds of entrepreneurs who are
trying to launch their dream um I mean
your t-shirt says it is you don't
believe believe I mean they're going to
be you know I studied my grandfather's
history and he was like the ultimate
entrepreneur in our family because it
started from nothing no I inherited
something and I'm making it better but
he started from nothing and I always say
like if people aren't ridiculing what
you're trying to do then you're not on
to something
so see that negative you know trolling
you no disparagement as a sign that
you're close to something important
unless like you're really being a jerk
and you know but most I mean I think
most entrepreneurs you know you have an
idea that like nobody has seen before or
and I mean most good entrepreneurs it's
like something new and there's going to
be people some people who support you
and think you're great and other people
who think you know you don't know
anything and just believe in yourself
and test it out and listen and do your
research and your your homework and and
and don't be afraid to iterate and
change and evolve and learn and grow it
and then you know if it doesn't work out
don't be afraid to walk away and it's
you know my grandfather launched a lot
of magazines that failed before he
launched magazines that worked so you
have to be willing to walk away from
things that aren't working we call those
people who don't believe in you the
little man here the what the little man
is a hashtag little man campaign ignores
a little man we have t-shirts with the
little man with an X to it because
there's always gonna be people who who
don't believe in what you're doing and
were so willing to throw things at you
and say all the reasons why it's not
going to work but don't have any guts to
stand up and do anything themselves
that's right that's little man I'm sure
there's a there's a lot of little women
too so that's true little man is a
shorter it's easier to remember Maria
thank you so much your gender what thank
you so much for spending the time with
us today where can people learn more
about you and your business and
everything that you're up to well they
can come to our corporate site is rodel
inc com my blog is Maria's farm country
kitchen calm my store is Road else calm
and of course you know all of our brands
have their own sites you know so ment
health women's health prevention organic
life runners world bicycling it's it's
that there's a lot out there so I hope
people come and find come and find us
and of course i'm on twitter and
facebook awesome i will throw all those
links in the description for everybody
watching Maria thank you so much your
time I really really appreciate it's
been an awesome discussion and I'm
really grateful that you took the time
out of your day to spend with us today
thank you so much evident thanks for all
you do it's awesome all right take care